bien
quiero que me acompañen a una cafetería
que se imagina en una cafetería en la
que en la mesa de hasta el fondo hay una
persona sentada que no has visto no
conoces nunca la has topado no es
platico con ella no sé quién es es nueva
en tu dieta y yo te pido que vayas y te
sientes con esa persona y en ese momento
te pido que la ames
así tal cual que la ames serías capaz de
amarla podría realmente amarla
y creo que pasa lo mismo con el amor
propio un tema que me encanta tocar en
mis redes sociales del amor propio
porque es algo que para mí como un
despertar de mi ser que cuando yo
entendí realmente quiere ese amor propio
que tenemos aquí guardado del que todos
hablan y lo sentimos como ok ok es esto
entonces vengan a tocar ese tema y
muchos de los que me siguen me preguntan
ver cómo le hago porque le oferte veo
fuera aquí le pregunto qué ejercicios
haces tú qué te sirve lalala a lo que yo
contesto conocerte y es a lo que voy con
este ejercicio no puedes amar a alguien
que no conoces es imposible porque
porque no sabes ni ni por dónde empezar
no sabes qué le quieres compartir no
sabes qué quieres escuchar de él y pasa
lo mismo con tu persona les va a contar
un poquito de mi historia yo empecé en
redes sociales cuando tenía 15 años
aproximadamente yo empecé a hacer un
perfil público qué quiere decir como que
empecé a ganar seguidores y empecé como
a desarrollarme en esta parte de lo
influencer
yo tengo una pelea muy grande porque me
costó mucho trabajo pero el tema del
positivismo tóxico en las redes sociales
es una locura es una locura porque te
engancha en un tema del que tú como
consumidor estás viendo en una pantalla
a las personas que tú quisiste seguir
porque por algo te inspira entonces tú
constantemente estás viendo que esa
persona quiere siempre demostrar lo
mejor de esa persona que siempre está
arreglada que ya entrenó que todo el día
te dice venga si se puede estamos súper
motivados y ser esa persona y unirse a
esa persona que a pesar de que yo me
sentía vacía yo me sentía mal
yo quería demostrar en mis redes
sociales que todo estaba bien que la
motivación de todo que aunque tuvieras
triste puede estar feliz cuando no es
así la vida
entonces yo cuando era consumidora de
las redes sociales yo empecé a ver esto
y yo que quería llegar a este punto de
convertirme en esa persona que yo veía
tan perfecta en la pantalla que yo
seguía entonces yo intenté hacer eso
entonces de mis redes sociales yo
siempre era la persona contenta a la
persona alegre donde siempre como les
frase pantelis no sabían que yo lloraba
cuando terminaba de grabar mi historia
claramente eso no los no lo contamos
y ahí es cuando yo como que y de aliste
la perfección como que yo creí que eso
era lo que estaba bien y empecé a
ponerme expectativas muy altas como el
cómo me tenía que ver físicamente
entonces yo empecé a poner una
expectativa en mi cabeza de ok este no
es el cuerpo que yo veo y a las que yo
sigo entonces tengo que hacer era algo
para tener ese cuerpo tengo que hacer
algo para tener los amigos que esté
viendo que esta niña que sigo tiene
porqué saber muy cool o tengo que tener
al novio para las fotos perfectas y los
viajes perfectos y empecé a esta
ansiedad que en vez de procurar me a me
empecé a incrementar una ansiedad que
todavía no sé demostrar ya después tuve
muchas crisis de identidad que les voy a
platicar en un ratito pero ahí como que
yo todavía no era consciente del poco
amor propio que yo me tenía yo como que
yo ya está bien con altibajos todo bien
yo estudiante entré a mi primera
relación que fue yo creo que la que más
me pegó pero la que más me ayudó yo
entré a una relación yo sin creer que yo
valía algo entonces en el momento que yo
me entrego una persona y veo que esta
persona me recibe con los brazos
abiertos y me quiere yo yo me sentía que
era un privilegio que alguien me
quisiera
si él me quiere es porque él es
increíble y gracias por querer mentos yo
agradecía porque la gente se preocupaba
por mí porque la gente me quisiera
porque realmente yo no me quería
entonces yo si alguien mandó hacía como
wow porque lo estás haciendo qué raro
guau me encanta ya sabes pasa como todo
empieza tiene que acabar empezamos una
relación a los 17 años claramente no iba
a ser para siempre como en mi cabeza lo
decía me corta esta persona de un día
para otro me corto sin explicación
alguna en ese momento mi mundo se vino
abajo y ese fue el día clave en que yo
me di cuenta que no me quería
absolutamente nada que todo mi ser se lo
había entregado esta persona que yo me
había vaciado por llenar posibilitará
las expectativas que yo tenía de mí pero
con otra persona cuando no eran los
reales y entonces ahí fue cuando dije
creo que tengo que ir a terapia e
intente de todo no saben intenté terapia
intenté tatuar me ha mandado primero en
las pastillas tengo otro de amor propio
yo quería llenarme porque yo si es que
chances y me lo repito siempre pues es
porque así me va a entrar y lo me voy
amar y no la realidad es que es un
ejercicio del día a día que es muchísimo
más que solamente pensar que tienes el
amor propio pero entonces empiezo con
terapia
la parte de mi charla que quiero contar
es que una vil libreta que justa la
tengo aquí porque es mi compañera de
vida cambió mi vida yo cuando corto con
esta relación empiezo una terapia en el
psicólogo mi primera vez en el psicólogo
que me ayudó muchísimo y empecé con una
libretita chiquitita me acuerdo perfecto
a escribir exactamente todo lo que
sentía si yo estaba enojada escribía
agarrar mi libreta y escribe estoy
enojada porque por esto porque me hizo
sentir así esta situación lo cerraba
sería comida si yo estaba feliz escribía
hasta el feliz por esta situación y esto
me hizo sentir así y listo que iba lo
cerraba y ahí lo dejaba y entonces
empecé a hacer como más consciente con
mi libreta pero como todavía no tenía
este balance es decir ya me conozco ya
sé quién soy hasta dónde se para desde
hace cuánto algo no había no tenía idea
pero esta libretita fue como mi diario
mini exo por tics entre otra relación en
la que yo creía estar mejor pero me
empieza al amor y otra vez como a mí me
faltaba pues yo lo agarré esta persona
que me lo estaba dando y entonces le di
toda mi valía a esa persona y yo quería
hacer todo para él quería por lo mejor
para él
y ahí entra a mi libreta al rescate yo
cada que me sentía mal me sentía vacía o
esta persona me hace sentir mal o me
hace sentir menos o lo que sea
claramente cuando no estás bien buscas
pues relaciones tóxicas
entonces yo abría mi libreta escribía
todo y leía lo que había sido de mi ser
del día anterior si yo había estado
triste ayer si yo estaba triste que hoy
leía porque estaba triste analizada la
situación decía ok ahorita ya creo que
puedo contar esta parte y anotar por lo
que ahora estaba triste y por lo que no
podía controlar y así fue como yo empecé
a aprender a poner límites de decir
sabes que esto no me gusta porque yo
antes era incapaz de decir esto no me
gusta lo que sea y si y si se enojan
conmigo y si piensan que soy así y
entonces yo todo el temporal el que
dirán que van al estilo de mí si yo
pongo un límite que van a decir de mí si
digo esto no me gusta entonces así
empecé a lograr poner límites en mis
relaciones y empecé a decir esto no me
gusta esto si me gusta esto no me gusta
total para no hacerlo es el cuento largo
claramente llega un día en el que todo
se junta y yo ya no me sentía contenta
con esta relación pero yo no era capaz
de cortar a alguien porque yo decía que
va a pensar la gente yo le estoy
diciendo a mis redes sociales que esto
siempre que estás mis relaciones son muy
felices cuando la realidad es que pero
no está feliz que algo le falta hacer y
en ese momento decidí ponerme a mí
primero y creo que fue una graduación
del amor propio así yo lo tomo el haber
dicho voy a cortar a esta persona sin
razón alguna más que a mí ya no me hace
feliz me agarre toda la fuerza interna
que encontré en ese momento llegue lo
cité y dije lo siento ya no puedo estar
contigo claramente yo dije me voy a
arrepentir mañana no voy a encontrar
algo mejor les juro que en cuanto hice
eso como que mi alma me apapacha vendrá
a mí y ahí fue cuando empezó este
despertar que empecé a escuchar lo que
pero necesitaba entonces fue como un les
juro que algo en mí me dijo gracias y
sentí una paz que dije esto es lo que
necesitaba para aprender a escucharme
aprender a decir que no aprender a decir
que sí cuando quería y ahí es donde
entra esta libreta esta libreta me ayudó
a youth ser capaz de reconocer mis
emociones le dio ser capaz de reconocer
que estaba bien que estaba mal que
estaba permitiendo y que no estaba
permitiendo y empezar a conocerme y
entonces a lo que voy es yo creo que el
amor propio es un ejercicio del día con
día somos seres que estamos en constante
cambio
y como estamos en constante cambio
quiere decir que ayer no somos los
mismos que estamos hoy y está libre
también me ayudó para entender mi yo del
pasado y hacer este cambio que yo quiero
para hacer la persona que quiero ser en
un futuro y la que soy ahorita en este
momento hablando con ustedes entonces
para mí fue lo que a mí me motivó mucho
y además yo nunca me creí capaz de poder
inspirar a alguien y cuando empecé a ser
consciente de las personas que me
escribían para pedirme consejos de las
personas que me felicitaban por lo que
había hecho empecé a decir cuellos iba
algo como esto esto es lo más bonito que
he tenido y soy yo y no lo explotó de la
manera que lo tenemos que explotar y los
quiero dejar con una frase que a mí me
encanta y que es muy corta pero siempre
la tengo en mente que es preciso meter
porque te has costado mucho trabajo
porque creo que lo que más cuesta es
conocernos creo que los jueces más
crueles para nosotros somos nosotros
mismos entonces en el momento que te
aprendes a para tachar en el momento que
te abrazas y que está aquí estoy me voy
a escuchar qué es lo que yo necesito en
ese momento cambia absolutamente todo
muchas gracias